por primera vez desde hace tres días
Vimos a la familia real salir del
castillo de balmoral En todo caso los
miembros de la familia real que todavía
están allí salieron en cuatro
automóviles y fueron a un servicio
religioso privado en una capilla muy
cerca de aquí de este castillo de
balmoral y mientras tanto pues había
cientos de personas que esperaban a que
pudieran dejar las flores y los
diferentes mensajes que han venido
trayendo desde hace tres días hasta las
rejas finalmente de de balmoral esta
salida de familia real en la que estaban
los tres hijos de la Reina Isabel que
todavía están aquí la princesa Ana el
príncipe Eduardo y el príncipe Andrés
pues formaban parte de estas de estas
personas de este grupo de personas que
estuvieron en este servicio religioso no
duró más de media hora esa salida y
luego los vimos y justamente allí a la
reja donde todas estas personas que como
ustedes verán siguen trayendo flores y a
mensajes pues han venido a depositarse
era un momento pues muy esperado de
hecho la familia real incluso descendió
justamente aquí de los vehículos y fue
caminando hasta la reja Es la primera
vez que los vemos y bueno Esto digamos
ya son los últimos momentos de la
familia real aquí en balmoral de hecho
del féretro de la Reina Isabel antes de
que sea pues se ha transportado a
edimburgo eso será en la mañana de este
domingo